Oh amazing liar hello close your eyes
and you imagine a heavy place what's the
first thing that you think of I think of
a garden and in this garden I can just
imagine various flowers and they grow
and also there's a fruit tree and a lot
of birds visit the garden it's
permanently sunshine there's no rain and
as a hammock what we could have is a
lion's head that spouts water coming out
of the mouth and that water is ginger
ale what what did you want to be when
you were growing up a ballet dancer
ballet dancer yeah well I imagine there
there could be a small stage with velvet
curtains oh that's a music we could have
a little band elves okay
[Music]
your eyes oh wow those beautiful blue
butterflies it's just the color is just
up who's that on there on top of the
who's that
that's just amazing look at that there's
my hammock but attempting to sit down
[Music]
beautiful oh I can see bubbles closing
in it
oh look at that that was absolutely
amazing the clay carp were beautiful and
the butterflies the mind just goes into
a world of fantasy it was the most
fascinating experience I've ever had
[Music]
you